[Music]
on this Friday night a heartbreaking
Homecoming in Nova Scotia
residents get a look at what's left of
their neighborhood it has has been well
it's gone the province is unprecedented
firefight with the weather finally
offering some relief
flight disruptions I can check in but I
can't check out Fallout from Air
Canada's latest technical troubles and
concern about the busy travel season
ahead
plus ER emergency how Staffing struggles
are hitting hospitals across the country
and e-bike boom and bust holy mackerel
so what'll happen now how BC's rebate
program proved too popular for its own
good
global national
reporting tonight Sophie Lewis
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight again in Nova Scotia
The Province grappling with forest fires
unlike any it has seen before more
International help is on the way six
water bombers are headed to Nova Scotia
this weekend from Montana to support
Crews that have been working hard to
battle the flames and there was some
good news today in the form of rain
which gave firefighters a bit of relief
I've never been so happy to see rain as
I was this morning and I'm sure many
people across the region feel the same
way it was great it's going to help slow
down fire spread today but it's not
enough well luckily a lot more rain is
in the forecast for the weekend but for
some people it sadly didn't come soon
enough earlier today some residents were
allowed to go see the damage up close
that's where we begin our coverage
tonight with Mike Armstrong Mike
Sophie this roadblock is as far as
evacuees have been allowed to go since
being forced out of their homes on
Sunday today they were given the chance
to at least briefly visit their
neighborhood some jumped at the chance
for others it was still too painful
the invitation went out Thursday night
for a bus tour but with a hitch during
the visit no one would be allowed off my
house is gone everything's gone Jody
Stewart decided not to take the bus and
to wait to go home he said he'd rather
go back when he can actually stop and
with family a drive-by wouldn't really
cut what I need to do there
well not closure I don't know what it's
called but I need to actually physically
go and do my thing
five buses went to different parts of
the evacuation Zone depending on where
people lived the tour lasted about an
hour buses stopped in front of people's
homes the house is gone the is gone
and everything's gone like this on our
property there's nothing left it's
completely gone Jason and Mary young
knew what to expect they'd seen some
pictures
during the tour one thing they
appreciated was being with neighbors I
mean we were all there just hugging each
other and we would stop and just people
would stare at their properties and just
break down but we would be there for
each other and giving words of comfort
to each other because we understand what
we're all what we're going through it's
getting in those needles Global News has
obtained video shot this week as homes
burned down the images were taken by
someone who stayed inside the evacuation
Zone defying the mandatory order to
leave the video was sent to Global
unsolicited it shows the ferociousness
of the fire and the devastation it left
behind it also shows how the ground
continues to smoke with hot spots even
after the main fire has moved on that is
exactly what firefighters are working on
trying to prevent a phenomenon called
holdover those small little ambers hide
and just you know when you think
everything's fine they can come back to
the surface and you can get a reignition
there's been enough progress on the 10
Talon fire that more of the evacuation
zone is being opened up but still only
about 50 percent contained there have
also been other fires in the region
Thursday was according to the deputy
fire chief the busiest day in memory
stretched the department so thin it put
about 20 recruits into service people
who haven't actually graduated that is
unusual that is not our preference trust
me those recruits may be used again
they officially finish their training
their graduation ceremony may have to be
delayed
apartment is just too busy Mike
Armstrong Global News upper 10 Town Nova
Scotia
and as of this morning there were 15
active fires burning across Nova Scotia
so that weekend rain can't come soon
enough
a steady stream of helicopters and
bombers tackling the largest fire the
province has ever seen in Shelburne
County in southern Nova Scotia the fire
creating a huge plume of smoke across
the region more than 40 volunteer and
Municipal firefighters are working on it
from the air and on the ground
and Quebec's Fire Protection Agency is
warning that its ability to stay on top
of the fires in that province is
becoming more and more difficult this
blaze in setil on Quebec's North Shore
is one of 80 burning out of control it
has resulted in an evacuation order
affecting as many as 5 000 people
Canada's Airlines have been trying to
reassure Travelers that last Summer's
flight and baggage chaos won't happen
again this year but a technical
malfunction at Air Canada on Thursday
felt all too familiar
there were so many cancellations and so
many delays that we thought I thought
for sure that we were going to get
delayed today or Canada says the I.T
issue has now been resolved but not
before 500 flights at nine of Canada's
busiest airports were delayed or
canceled as Karen Lieberman reports some
are wondering if a post-pandemic surge
in demand will mean more disruptions
ahead
we were on Route and I we got a garbled
message on the phone saying our my
flight was canceled too late to turn
around this traveler will wait out the
delay at the airport like many others
this is my first flight in like six
months so yeah no issue actually we're
delayed an hour today so welcome back
right
while air travel may be returning to
pre-pandemic levels a variety of issues
from Staffing to technology has been
casting a dark cloud on the aviation
industry we are almost at 2019 numbers
there are a lot of people traveling and
in Canada specifically you know we have
the looming WestJet strike the Air
Canada Pilots might be going on strike
so there are a lot of people that are
concerned on how are they actually going
to get off the ground on Thursday many
didn't for the second time in a week Air
Canada experienced a system-wide
technical issue the result we were
supposed to leave today but our flight
as of now has been delayed an hour we
try to call the 800 number that's like
they said they can help us we have to
show up to the airport it is their
systems their planes their
responsibility this air passenger rights
Advocate says it's not the passenger's
responsibility to chase the airline for
information
the law says that the airline has to
communicate to the passengers
proactively they have to make
announcements they have to send emails
and they have to provide alternate
Transportation by Friday Air Canada
noted its Communicator system now
stabilized was functioning normally but
that rollover effects may result in
delays they told me to go and get my own
hotel phone in the morning this Air
Canada traveler is frustrated and wanted
to send a message I hope to CEO is
listening sir I work in your industry I
do Medicals on your pilots and you need
to come down here and straighten this
out on this traveler's mind recouping
costs for
to fight for the compensation and it
should be cut and dry if this happens
then you get refunded the federal
government recently tabled new rules
meant to make it harder for Airlines to
deny compensation for travelers
experiencing lost baggage delays and
cancellations
Sophie Karen Lieberman reporting for us
tonight Karen thank you hospitals are
also bracing for a busy summer as more
people enjoy activities in The Great
Outdoors that can lead to injury and
trips to the emergency department but
this year a warning some of those ERS
may not be open Catherine Ward explains
why
in Minden Ontario there is no longer an
emergency room it means thousands of
ontarians will have to travel farther
and farther it closed June 1st
hours have been cut in Niagara where
officials say two urgent care centers
will close overnight service
the president and CEO says this time the
decision is permanent our own physician
leaders have told us that a difficult
summer lies ahead doctors say despite
sounding the alarm Staffing problems
persist there's many times like last
night on the night shift when I go back
to the nursing station about an urgent
request and there is no nurse I can't
find a nurse it's a story on repeat
across Canada in New Brunswick Alberta
and BC there's not enough staff to heal
the Health Care Systems forcing services
to shut down Canadian Medical
Association president Dr Alika lafonten
hopes new federal investments will help
relieve pressure but there are still
concerns about how to better manage
resources we should not treat this
summer
as if we've moved past the crisis we are
still in the middle of it but we're in a
better position to address it but we
have yet to do that doctors are
particularly really worried about what
will happen in rural communities this
summer a lot of rural volumes go up
because people from the cities are
heading to rural areas for vacation the
Ontario government announced it would
renew funding to help Rural and Northern
hospitals and bolster ER Staffing but
where the doors are already closed
residents are worried people are going
to die Canadians will be waiting longer
this summer The Crush on Emergency
Services has outstripped the ability of
the system to cope with it Catherine
Ward Global News Toronto
in Quebec a new law aimed at protecting
the French language has just come into
effect Bill 96 is an update to the
province's French language Charter and
it makes it harder to access services in
English the government calls it a vital
tool to stop the decline of Quebec's
only official language but opponents say
the province is going too far Dan's
Vector reports
Wade Wilson is a resident of London
Quebec a suburb just south of Montreal
on Thursday when he came to this splash
pad with his grandchildren it wasn't
working so my wife reached out to 3-1-1
to just find out exactly what was
happening and they basically told her
which still shocks me today that she
didn't have the right to be communicated
to in English
rule 96 is designed to stop the decline
of the French language especially in
Montreal most civil servants must now
communicate with citizens in French
people can still get health care in
English but here's what Montreal's 3-1-1
line sounds like when you choose English
we will be pleased to provide service in
English if you attest in good faith that
you are covered by one of the following
exceptions
if you are a person declared eligible to
receive English education
if you are an indigenous person if you
are a recently arrived you are only
allowed to access English Services if
you grew up going to English school and
in a few other cases though it's only
based on the honor System we want to ask
people to bring a card or something like
that the Montreal suburb of code St Luke
is 60 anglophone their new information
line message is Raising some eyebrows if
you'd like service in English press two
oh and by the way you don't need to show
us your grade 3 report card and you
don't have to pinky promise anything
this is the city of code St Luke and
that's how we roll I think it was I
think it's a good way to show the
absurdity of this uh this law Quebec
says people made fun of the original
French Charter bill 101 back in the 70s
too it's a new step and I think we
should be proud of that under Bill 96
immigrants must be able to communicate
with the government in French within six
months of their arrival I would suggest
to some of the people who have
implemented this law to try it
themselves to try learning another
language in six months enough to be able
to function totally in that language but
French Classes aren't always immediately
available and the website for the
government's new French language
instruction agency is only available in
French I have asked my teams to make it
easier to reach the website build 96
also imposes new regulations on
businesses schools and more it's already
facing multiple legal challenges to
inspector Global News Montreal
Russia continues a massive attack on
Kiev coming up the U.S pledges more
military support for Ukraine plus infant
formula can still be hard to find the
lengths some parents are going to to
find a supply
[Music]
a frantic effort to save lives in India
tonight after two trains collided in the
Eastern State of odisha it appears one
train jumped the track and smashed into
another there are reports at least 120
people are dead and Rescuers are
scrambling tonight to find survivors
well the U.S Secretary of State is
pledging more International military
support for Ukraine even as Russia
continues a massive missile and drone
attack on Kiev the Ukrainian Capital was
hit with more than two hours of Ariel
and bombardment overnight as Ukrainian
forces prepare for a counter-offensive
in Secret locations Jennifer Johnson has
the latest
in the dark of night Russia fired at
least 36 missiles and drone strikes in
Kiev marking the deadliest week in
Ukraine's capital in months thousands of
people are Sheltering in the city's
subway stations trying to survive
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
is at NATO meetings overseas pledging
long-term funding to help Ukraine fight
back America and our allies and partners
are helping meet Ukraine's needs on the
current Battlefield
while developing a force that can deter
and defend against aggression for years
to come
Ukraine is now holding large-scale
military training exercises preparing
for a counter-offensive against Russia
in the air and on the ground
this pilot saying we need more missiles
and helicopters but we've been preparing
for this since 2014. this week the U.S
is sending additional Munitions for
Patriot air defense systems while on the
ground U.S troops and soldiers from
other NATO countries are training
Ukraine's military in a secret location
Kremlin often claimed it had the second
strongest military in the world and many
believed it
today many see Russia's military as the
second strongest in Ukraine meanwhile
NATO leaders are moving ahead with plans
for Ukraine to join NATO something
Russian President Vladimir Putin
strongly opposes knowing it will greatly
strengthen the country he wants to
control all our agree that Ukraine will
become a member of the alliance and all
allies agree that it is for the NATO
allies and Ukraine to decide when the
time is right it's not for Moscow to to
decide the key remains under attack a
criminal investigation has now been
launched after missile fragments hit
outside a locked keyved Health Center
used as a shelter killing three people
officials fear another night of shelling
as Ukraine prepares to launch a massive
operation to strike back
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
[Music]
met on global national the struggle to
find Formula how shortages persist
across the country and the temporary
solutions that could help
[Music]
there's some relief for families on the
hunt for baby formula with health Canada
approval for a product from France
parents across the country have faced
shortages for more than a year and while
let's hope the French formula will be of
some help some say it won't be enough
Marnie blunt reports
Renee blunderfield has her hands full
caring for her 10 month old daughter
and the simple Act of feeding her baby
is a source of stress it's been very
stressful and absolutely ridiculous
driving around from location and
location to find some food for your
infant a shortage of baby formula making
food scarce the shelves are bare there's
like next to nothing so
what are we supposed to do blunderfield
has numerous relatives trying to help
her find the formula she needs including
her father who has driven to more than
15 different cities and towns well it's
annoying when you know you have a
grandchild who is in need a specific
formula and there's no idea of when it's
going to become available parents have
been grappling with shortages since
February of last year when Abbott a
major producer of formula shut down its
Michigan plant after four babies
suffered bacterial infections from
consuming powdered formula two died
recently another recall of Gerber baby
formula South of the Border made the
supply situation even more dire supplies
are quite tight so Americans are
desperate to supply their own market and
we rely on the American Market to get
our own baby formula in Canada so as you
can imagine
exporters aren't necessarily
prioritizing the game market last week
week Health Canada gave interim approval
to import a baby formula from France in
a matter of weeks but blunderfield says
she feels it won't be enough leaving her
and many other parents on a stressful
search for food for their babies we need
to feed our children so
what are we supposed to do wait until
shipment comes and then the shelves go
bare and then repeat all over again
Health Canada says it is working with
manufacturers to increase amount and
types of product which included
establishing an interim policy to bring
in formula from other countries that
have similar standards to Canada that
policy has been extended until the end
of this year Sophie morning blunt in
Winnipeg Forest tonight thanks Marnie
BC's e-bike rebate program proved so
popular it sells out in mere hours what
happens next
[Music]
well the popularity of e-bikes is
exploding worldwide the power assisted
bicycles making it easier and faster to
get around with the added benefit of
being environmentally friendly and some
Canadian jurisdictions are fueling the
demand offering cash back incentive
programs BC was the latest to do so this
week with a startling results Kamal
karamali explains
electric bikes are on a roll
and there's no signs of sales slowing
down I was being quite busy uh bikes at
the door bikes coming in thank you very
much Thursday BC introduced a cash
incentive allocating six million dollars
to fund e-bike rebates applicants can
get anywhere from 350 to 1400 back
depending on their income the website
crashed from the high demand perhaps we
need to work on our technology
infrastructure a little bit the entire
fund appears to have been used up by the
end of its first day on Thursday the BCE
bike rebate program had over 5500
applicants
Laura yopas is one of hundreds now on a
wait list obviously I've already been
thinking about it but uh definitely the
announcement kind of like made me pull
the trigger several customers putting
bikes on hold until applicants rebates
come through but others gave up once the
website crashed critical of the The
Province for failing to meet the demand
it was clear that that it yeah it was
overloaded oh yeah for sure but it's not
just BC e-bikes soaring in popularity
across Canada the rebate programs are
giving it a big boost in 2020 Edmonton
backpedaled on the rebate after it
surged in popularity BC is the latest
Province to hop on the e-bike rebate
program UConn offers back as much as 750
Alberta Nova Scotia and Pei offering 500
but the largest Province and its largest
city have no plans part of it is a
matter of money we've like the
municipalities work on limited budgets
former Toronto City councilor Mike
Layton brought forward a motion in 2021
but a change in government put the
brakes on the idea it passed fortunately
I it didn't come back in that term of
council unfortunately and I don't
believe it's come back since many cities
instead have an e-bike share program but
some believe it's just a matter of time
until those who aren't on board with
rebates will switch gears Kamal coromali
Global News North Vancouver BC
and that's global national for this
Friday night I'm Sophie Louis tonight's
your Canada is Summerside Prince Edward
Island we love seeing your Canada so
please email your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
foreign Esser will be back at the anchor
desk tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
foreign